my talk is about kind of NLP a little
bit but kind of more around Jensen and
kind of what it offers as a as a package
for doing natural language processing
and kind of some of the models that
exposes some of the kind of text
processing you can do with it I found it
to be not super either well-known or
used quite as much as kind of other
tools out there in the in the pike go
Python ecosystem
you know TK is is obviously used a lot
and really well-known and I'll talk a
little bit about how NLT can kind of
augment Jensen because Jensen tries to
be kind of a smaller package in terms of
what it can do it's it's really focused
on a couple things which i think is
really good it's not doesn't try to do
too much so we kind of just talked about
Jen somehow I've used in the past how
you can all use it for for you know
either the kind of text analytics side
of it or potentially kind of the
querying side of natural language
processing if you want to kind of build
a pseudo search engine or do similarity
matches for however you kind of want to
define your your documents at all I'll
talk about a couple alternative
definitions of documents that you can
potentially use and using other aspects
so the kind of the rough outline for
this talk want to give kind of a quick
introduction to MLP super quick five
minutes not going to not going to teach
you the low-level details here but just
enough so when I start using terms later
you may have heard it so and then kind
of want to talk a little bit about Jen
some at least the background of it you
know where you can find more resources
on how to use it in the future you know
I promise it's being actively developed
I hate when I someone's like oh this is
a great great package you should use it
and it you know hasn't been developed in
over a year talking about some of the
mechanics of Jen's some and kind of a
workflow and the workflow that I've used
hopefully you know if you're kind of
going off and like oh I have this
awesome corpus that I want to analyze
you know hopefully this will kind of
give you the workflow of oh I have these
documents how do I do some
transformations on them and potentially
model model the outcomes
then we're gonna talk about a couple
kind of use cases examples so I'll talk
about my background here a sec but I've
worked on kind of building
recommendation systems in a prior job
where we're able to kind of translate
using natural language focused models
and two more recommendation tools so I
kind of talk about that
and then kind of talk a little bit more
about of a what a purely kind of
analysis example where I looked at some
inaugural address from from presidents
all the way back to 1789 to the one in
2009 and just kind of not gonna talk
about like the findings of them just
kind of want to talk about again about
like the work flow and how I went from
oh I have these documents to oh now I
have some analysis that it might be
interesting to share so this is me I
just kind of guessed on the arrow just
kidding I you got to figure it out so
yes this is me this is when I was
younger and better-looking that's my my
Twitter and write a blog though I
haven't updated a long time my kind of
educational background is more focused
on kind of accounting and and
mathematical finance if you are at the
swarm optimization when you know that
accountants are potentially the most
annoying breed of person and that's me I
kind of transition more into kind of
media analysis and but then after that I
worked at a zoo Lilly which is a Seattle
company you know working on the data
science team doing kind of operational
analysis and recommendation systems
things like that and then I've since
left then run kind of a one-man kind of
freelance consulting group where I focus
more on kind of what I what I kind of
historically care about and of
algorithmic trading financial tech
things like that so NLP is is useful in
kind of all those aspects and I found
Jensen to be kind of a great kind of
prototyping language or even a
production language you can use it I
mean certainly there are tools out there
now like PI spark which which
as LD I believe and has word avec which
which might be more amenable if you have
massive data but some of the things
we'll talk about Jen some make it make
it usable for for a large amounts of
data even if you're only using one
machine that kind of like one of the
core tenants of Genesis in some is this
kind of screaming idea where you use
variational Bayes or other kind of
update procedures in the algorithm so
you don't have to store it all on memory
so I'll talk talk a little bit about
that but kind of first is an
introduction to to NOP and you know you
can't do it okay to five minutes it's
like you know you're not wrong you just
you know and this is pg-13 so yeah so so
I kind of think of NLP is and kind of
you know text analytics there's kind of
two broad spectrums that you're gonna
have this front side which and it's it's
it's not really that different from your
kind of generic machine learning that
you might be doing you have this kind of
like text encoding where you have a but
like a data set and you need to encode
it maybe do some you know dimensionality
reduction something like that so you can
actually have something worth worth
analyzing and then there's the kind of
the modeling aspects of it where you
know you might use Lda or where did that
can I'll talk a little bit about those
to try to kind of derive meaning or
drive some sort of you know something
you can fit in your head about like you
know these million documents and some
some kind of representation thereof so
so the first kind of part of of all
modeling natural language or or
otherwise is you know you have this like
raw data and you need to turn it into
vectors you basically turn it into
numbers so here we have kind of two two
examples this is a document this is not
a document I almost you know put this is
not a pipe I know the French stuff I
guess
so so this is this is kind of the the
most classic or I guess it's not really
the most classic this is kind of the
most common used text encoding
representation you can have it's called
like the vector space model there's
another one a little bit more
classically used called boolean standard
boolean model but
the vector space model is used as used
quite a bit more and so you've actually
seen this encoding I'm sure you have you
know if you use R and you have like a
text variable and you need to encode it
where you have you know say you have
like three different options and a
categorical variable and you need to
encode it you might you'll then
basically expand it out where you have
three columns and you'll have you know
so you have like a color as a feature of
your model and it could be red green or
blue you'll have a column for red I call
them for green and a column for blue and
then an indicator variable in that this
is really not too dissimilar from that
at all so you've you've seen this before
you just have you if you're not familiar
with NLP you might not have seen it
where like the entire data set is a
categorical variable so what you end up
having with this vector space model is
basically every individual term that's
how that's the dimensionality so you can
kind of think like if I have 20 terms in
my entire corpus that's going to be the
dimensionality of the of the vectors in
this kind of vector space model so this
is kind of the base representation after
that there's a lot of kind of encodings
you can do it on top of that one of the
kind of more common ones you'll see is
what's called tf-idf its term frequency
inverse document frequency which tries
to re weight the vectors based on how
often or how how infrequently they occur
in the underlying text this can be
really good for instance you see here
you know how we have this as a document
because of the ubiquity of this is a
document they're really kind of
meaningless if you were to kind of like
find some information because they're
present in the entire in the entire text
so you'll you'll want to use this kind
of inverse document frequency which is
which happens to be model and Jensen
where it can kind of go through your
corpus for you and andrey weight these
things so the the point of these last
two last three slides is really you know
we have this document or we have these
documents and we need to turn them into
vectors so so once you have once you get
there you kind of have this kind of
underlying problem where you have this
massive you know dimensionality problem
right if you have a million words in
your corpus you didn't have a
million your space that you're working
in is of size 1 million so you have a
real kind of problem finding anything
interesting you know this is why you
typically see cosine similarity used a
lot more than Euclidean distance in in
in NOP tools because they're they they
work a little bit better under these
high dimensional high dimensional spaces
that said there there are kind of two
broad models and transformations that I
would I would kind of classify when
doing NOP
you have these kind of decompositions
which is you know you take some either
spectral representation you projected
down into a lower dimensional space
these are kind of if you've seen like
pca
so it's a very kind of similar idea and
certainly there's there's you know the
these two topics it kind of meshed in in
together because you can have like
probabilistic pca or things like that so
it gets kind of they get kind of muddled
together however I guess I would kind of
if I were to categorize them in my brain
this is kind of how I would think of
about them they're both both outcomes
are really useful these decompositions
or maybe a little bit more for a little
bit better for querying you know I have
these two documents and here's their
representation after PCA and I want to I
want to find the similar documents
whereas probabilistic models are a
little bit more interpretable you can
say you know this document was kind of
arised due to you know it's probability
of whatever topic whatever topic at hand
so two kind of examples for that so so
one an example and I'm gonna talk a
little bit later and in the inaugural
address example is LD a so LD a is kind
of workhorse when it comes to natural
language processing you know the the
kind of basic idea is you have words
topics and documents documents arise or
kind of composed of some probability of
the individual topics so if you imagine
like I'm writing I'm writing a document
I'm going to select okay I'm gonna roll
a dice select a topic when I select that
topic I'm then going to select a word
from that topic based on the probability
of the word given the topic and then
write that
and so that's kind of the generative
model of Lda so you can do like really
kind of nice and useful things this is
from well actually there this is now
from the data lab at u-dub around but
it's just kind of a visualization
there's lots of tools out there and our
NAND Python for visualizing the outcomes
of Lda but what this kind of shows is
you know so you have these you have
these words over here and you have the
topics kind of up top and you have you
know what's the kind of probability or
the relative probability that the word
was generated from that topic you can
kind of slant this around a little bit
you know if you kind of think okay if a
document is a collection of words you
know one sláinte you might make is what
if a person is a collection of actions
right so you know you might have some
person who's shopping on a website if
you if you work it on a retailer or
something like that and then the
document or the words that they are then
showing might be the actions they're
taking on the site so you have these
kind of choices within a person and then
you can potentially try to kind of
create personas are really popular
nowadays and in online marketing so you
can kind of potentially create these
personas from the individuals that are
saying you know this kind of group of
people is really likely to have been
generated from this topic so that I
would classify as more kind of a
probabilistic approach another one is
word avec which is getting a lot of
popularity I have found this if I've
found word avec extremely useful for
kind of querying similarity searches and
things like that I've found it of
dubious interpretation though of like
what does this actually mean it's you
know quite often you'll have these
massive vectors and it's it's not super
clear how to how to use them beyond what
they're cosine similarity is or
something along those lines that said if
you do want to visualize these things
something like PCA on top of a word of a
courtier t-sne is another really good
choice of kind of decomposing these
vectors seeing it some visualization
there are two kind of broad topics or
broad kind of classes of word Tyvek
which is like kind of a continuous bag
of words which your your
using the kind of surrounding text
surrounding words to predict the word or
where you have kind of script ran model
where you have the word in general and
you're trying to predict kind of the the
words around it and and that kind of
classification process is what what
produces the the vectors you end up
using so that that was kind of roughly
the five minute introduction to NLP so
so now a little bit more focused on
Jensen so there there are a lot of tools
out there that you might have think you
might think of before you think of
Jensen the other scikit-learn which is
amazing Valpo rabbit's spark mallet you
know tons of these things and they're
they're all really good there's no doubt
about that however they all have maybe
disadvantages for kind of quickly
integrating you know in an LP model or
what's something you want to do
analytically with the data you actually
have you know second learn is great but
it's it's text analytics features or
maybe a little bit a little bit limited
and that's that's not by the the lack of
the developers ability it's more
probably not not of not of super focus
to them you have a power outlet which i
think is at least sponsored by i by the
good folks here at microsoft spark which
is getting really popular now it which
is kind of the it's been around and well
tested and whatnot the problem with all
these they require like quite a bit of
setup so like if I wanted to use vampire
Abitur mallet from Python you know quite
often you have to like shell out to
another commander or use it in some
these kind of like nasty overflows
whereas Jensen is it's kind of pure
Python you can just import it in I have
some examples later that show that so it
makes it quite a bit easier and that
that's kind of what I mean by low
friction is you can have your regular
Python code and you can just kind of
bring Jensen into it you know if you're
doing some some text processing or
something like that it's not a big step
to next you know integrate Jensen
whereas you know if you wanted if you
wanted to use you know mallet or
something like that it it
kind of take some additional overhead to
think about that whereas really you know
you probably want to focus more your
brainpower on on the problem at hand um
so so this is Jensen like all like all
great Python packages it's X for humans
I I was you know kind of interested in
it being a human I thought I could I
thought it could be useful so if you
want to learn more about it that's it
that's we can go the tutorials are
awesome if you really want to start
using Jensen just follow those tutorials
they're they're great
some some of particulars about about
Jensen here's its homepage github one
thing to notice is it's L GPL licensed
you know not your kind of typical MIT or
or Apache so if you do think about kind
of using this as part your system really
think about the ramifications of what
that license means and what you're
trying to do just you know be you know
be a good citizen we're all
professionals so it would be a
professional so so there's some some
kind of like next level of things going
on in Jensen which are not necessarily
reflected in the in the documentation
yet so there's some kind of automatic
like text summarization which is getting
pretty interesting there's some kind of
extensions to to word defect doctor Veck
which is which is kind of interesting
talk a little about why you might be
interested in inductive act as opposed
to a word lévesque I'm depending on your
your applications and then and then kind
of you know classification is is
becoming kind of interesting and a
little more usable with with word Tyvek
you actually kind of produce these
likelihoods scores and then use the
likelihood scores to make classification
calls so yeah so really so so that's
kind of the background to Jen zoom so
we're gonna talk a little more about
like kind of how you actually use it
right so there's these kind of workflows
or these kind of objects that exist
within Jensen and and how you use them
is kind of the focus of this next few
slides so here kind of features of
Jensen more at least kind of what it
what it says they are and so I kind of
want to break some of these down and
talk a little about kind of like their
use and and why
nice so we have memory independence
which which is great when you have tons
of text and you have a little bitty
computer the interfaces are really nice
and I'll show them this is this is what
I this is my favorite part about
Jensen's it's just so fast to go from
okay I have I have a document too
now I have vectors and now I have a
model that I can use for kind of further
analysis or recommendations or or
whatever your kind of particular use
cases you know and then there's these
various models which I'll show kind of
two examples of so so those memory
independence is is really important
Jensen is is designed you know with the
idea that you know if you have if you're
doing text analysis on millions and
millions of documents there's no way
you're going to be able to fit it into
memory so its main point is around
memory independence both from an
algorithmic perspective and the kind of
learning that it does and the algorithm
chooses to do that learning and then
there's and then there's operationally
the idea of around around screaming and
text and and basically reading lines off
disk as opposed to reading everything
off disk into memory and then moving
that moving those documents through
through the through the through the
model so you know I talked about very
independence I'm not so sure where the
Veck actually is a memory independent I
believe it grows linearly with the
corpus sized Lda I know for sure as via
Hoffman 2010 which is a really good
paper what I would recommend checking
out and then operationally there's this
kind of satellites which I just talked
about and it comes down and pretty
simple pretty simple stuff so here's an
example there's this smart open package
written by the same the same person who
writes Jensen you could do this in pure
Python really simply to we're just you
know reading lines off off disk not
really a hole in the entire corpus and
then sending him through um so so that's
kind of something to be be cognizant of
you know don't read everything to a list
and then pass it in you can I've trained
Lda on Jensen with you know millions and
millions of documents and it's really
not it's really not a problem as long as
you adhere to these couple things so so
some of the interfaces then
so Jensen has a couple of objects that
are specifically designed for dealing
with text so they have there's a there's
a dictionary which it's exactly kind of
what it sounds like
it contains the underlying vocabulary of
the of the corpus you're working with so
this what this means is kind of a
basically an index where you have a
mapping of IDs to two tokens
any of various kind of methods methods
around that that that are useful such as
converting the the text so for instance
converting my doc into the kind of bag
of words representation of that or
basically the the vector space kind of
representation there of the other part
the other side of this are kind of what
you define yourself which is the corpus
so the corpus typically looks looks
exactly like this I can get a little bit
more complex but the the main focus here
is you override the inter method and
then that's how you yield that's how you
yield your documents out so what you can
see is here I have this Doc's which is
just you know you have two documents
they're already separated into kind of a
list of lists you know obviously based
on what I just said if you have a
massive documents don't do this but for
the purposes of an example you can then
pass in this this set of documents to
this dictionary it will read through it
and then ascribe a an ID to to a term
and then once you do that you define
this corpus you override the inter
method you have your documents and you
just basically loop through them and
yield out the the bag of words
representation which is kind of like
this vector space model the only the
only thing that jinsim does is it tries
to be a little bit smart around the
sparsity issues that you'll have so for
instance you know if you had a million
words and you want to represent one
exactly as as you know like no and if
you had my doc you might only have two
two terms in there that are one and
you'd have you know you know 1 million
minus two as the zeros so Jensen will be
smart around that sparsity and not not
store zeros when it doesn't need to
so that that's kind of high level like
you know I have my documents I have my
dictionary and now I have my corpus the
next step after that is kind of doing
models and transformations and Jensen
kind of uses these two things somewhat
interchangeably in the sense that and I
do too
so you know transformations you have
word to vac or Lda or something like
that you're kind of transforming this
vector space representation into kind of
a set of topic probabilities or the you
know if you're if you're using dr.
Becker word to vector or LSI or
something like that these kind of lower
dimensional representations you know and
so I like to kind of think of these it's
kind of nice you know psychic learning
kind of spoils everybody in the sense
that the API is extremely standard
across different machine learning
algorithms you might do they kind of all
have this fit method they all have this
Train method they do a lot of the kind
of the same things that's it's different
and and separated from your from the
model at hand and Jensen is is pretty
similar they're you know kind of
fundamental you need to pass it a corpus
you'll pass it kind of set of quarks
which are model specific so you know if
you're doing lva you might have the
number of topics that you think or you
want to you want to kind of opera
already select or you know for for a
word of a cue you might kind of choose
it the you might choose the size of the
vector representation that you want but
kind of fundamentally it's all it all
kind of looks the same you'll just have
a couple different letters up front and
then the next step of that is after you
have the train model you didn't need to
kind of like access the vectors and so
what Jensen does is it uses the kind of
this array notation to produce to
produce the transformations for any
document so if I was to then you know
pass in my doc to this model it would
then the output of this call would be
the whatever the model produces via the
topic probabilities be at the the vector
associated with it so a couple of
they're just just kind of mechanics so
at some point you're gonna train a model
and then you're going to you know need
to save or load it so there's this kind
of neat
for for that to give an example of a
real-world example of kind of saving and
loading you know one thing we would do
is we would train to model on you know
kind of a really big beefy machine save
it and then push it out to various
servers so it can kind of be be local to
to the the actual API whoever is making
the API call to get the scores so this
kind of model IO is not not that
interesting but but useful and then
there's you know so it so in in kind of
NOP literature there's these various
kind of formats that are kind of quite
often used SVM light is is not LD a
specific but it's it's used quite a bit
too to ignore sparsity issues or at
least get by them to some degree David
Blake for the Blake corpus is pretty
well known and then there's a low corpus
leads very there's very options of
serializing and deserializing both your
corpuses and your models so I mentioned
earlier that the LDA
are issues me the Jensen is is pretty
like small in its scope so this is
probably the best you're going to get in
terms of text cleaning so so be aware
and and I I like that though I mean I'm
actually a fan of trying to do what you
do really well and and outsourcing or or
getting other people to do the stuff
that you're that you don't do well so so
this is where I say you probably need
more and this is where NL TK and this is
kind of what I was saying earlier where
I plug plug in ulti for just a bit you
know so things like stop words stemming
those kind of things which are kind of
the fit and finish of an NLP model are
contained better within NL TK or are
kind of more useful there or or more
robust at least the the kind of features
there so just should kind of be aware of
that so so that's kind of that's kind of
the background so I want to kind of give
kind of go in a couple case studies and
kind of just give you some examples of
of Jensen in real life so it's it's demo
time yeah I didn't realize there were
you know a 12 foot tall
lacking in flight alarm in yeah above me
okay so this is an example that's really
tiny so Jensen happens to be extremely
simple to kind of plug into other other
Python libraries so I'm gonna wanted to
show that so here we have that it's just
awesome so here we have I know there's a
lot of code and all I'm gonna break it
down here in a second but this is
basically a you know you kind of think
of this it I wouldn't put this from the
production certainly but at a very kind
of like example of a really cheap simple
recommendation system that you can use
Jensen for so this uses flask to kind of
handle the HTTP requests but then it
uses this word to Veck to to Train so we
can see is kind of do this for example
as you can see you know if I have these
three products I can then you know pass
in kind of a term to say oh you know
give me the vector representation of
that and now I have a little API where
somebody can you know hit it hit my API
and say you know I have this term what
is its vector representation or I have
this product you know what is its vector
representation which you know the vector
in and of itself is maybe not so
interesting what what is interesting
then is you when you have multiple
products or multiple words and you want
to know the similarity the similarity
between them so that's we can do
something like this so say you had an
individual who
we've just made like one choice product
see right so that's so you know I made a
purchase and it happened to be product C
and you know maybe maybe later on your
page you have kind of an Amazon yes
you know you might also like or you know
you might also be interested in this so
what you might do there say you know if
you're the website designer or you're
kind of writing the website you want
some way to fill that up so you say oh
this person chose product day let me
then you know make a request to the
server and find out what other products
are similar to that kind of fundamental
or that underlying product see your
product error or what have you so what
this is doing and I'll show how this
works
in a second is it's basically running a
kind of a cosine similarity between the
choice the customer made and the various
other terms in our corpus which here
just happens to be product a and product
B and returning the similarity then you
could do some ranking or something like
that
to then kind of produce producer
recommendations
yes let's see so we talked about the
term weight kind of talked about the
similar products there's the nasty code
you don't to look at so here's kind of
the here's the here's the training part
or I guess maybe more the instantiation
part so we have these products so if you
actually if you if you remember earlier
when I showed like okay this is very
similar to how the other models work by
hat model name and then you know random
random clogs this is what you know you
might actually see for a word of X if ik
where you have these that the input
corpus you have men count which which
word of that kind of says you know as
I'm scanning through this text how many
how big should my window be and then the
the size is you know how big you kind of
want your basically how big is the
projection vector and so that was ten so
if you noticed on the website we looked
at just a second ago the vector that
vector you saw was of length 10 so
that's that's where that came from so
yeah so there's how to create size
there's that window trimming is really
useful so as I taught like I talked
about earlier
you know there's this kind of idea
behind continuous training and being
able to update and stream in additional
documents to your to your model but one
thing you might want to one thing you
might realize is that as you train a
really big model the model itself
becomes really big not even the corpus
itself and this is why I referenced
earlier weird effect maybe not being
completely size independent with respect
to the corpus but one thing you can do
is you can trim that you can trim the
underlying vectors and what that means
is I'll compute the l2 norms of the word
vectors however that limits your ability
to do do additional training on top of
that because it basically Clips your
vectors off so you can't train
additionally but it massively reduces
the size of the model where it's you
know for instance like the example I
gave earlier if you're saving that
serializing and shipping it off you
might want to kind of operate trim those
vectors before you ship it off to the to
the servers to actually do the actually
do the kind of recommendations so this
is the this is the part we're actually
kind of doing the recommendation and
then like kind of doing the retraining
so you saw you know I had my choices and
then I had that vector of choices I made
this most similar cosine is basically
doing the cosine similarity between the
the word or the words in question and
all the all the other terms so this
would be products for example but it
could really be anything and we're
returning kind of a stacked list and so
that was that's that's this we're kind
of producing these and I do a little bit
you know so you can serialize them so
you can move it across the wire but
that's that's what these are doing and
I'm retraining it so you can kind of
imagine as you get more and more
information you're just basically
sending documents into this training and
you're getting more you're getting
better updates and then there's you know
similarly there's the transformation
inside of this where you're you know and
so this this was those ten that's what
I've kind of showed earlier where I'm
getting the term and then I'm kind of
producing the result vector and then
returning it back so this is you know
this is the just kind of like
Diagnostics or like
you know if I have this term what is
what does it look like No so in terms of
of similarity methods there's there a
lot that are available so there's you
know most similar go sign there's then
most similar there's in similarity and
this doesn't match which which i think
is kind of cool I don't know if you ever
if you ever play the game when you were
you know like six years old or whatever
we you had like a cucumber and then a
banana then an apple and then an orange
and like well which one of those is
least similar or doesn't it doesn't
match the rest I was I was probably
jaded as a child but so so that's kind
of weird to Veck you know it tends to
work work pretty well one one kind of
quick quick thing this is a maybe so so
weird a Veck is can be really useful but
you end up getting these vectors on a
term basis this can be a little
challenging if you're trying to do like
aggregations or you know say say I'm a
so kind of the the fundamental kind of
the way we've kind of been viewing this
problem is a person is a document the
products they purchase our terms
so you get the terms for the products
they purchase however you might want to
say okay you know how similar is Trent
to the seller customer so that's
probably a really natural next question
to ask or you know if you're doing some
sort of clustering and you want to say
oh you don't have these ten emails to
send let me I'm a kind of cluster them
into groups if you only if you're only
kind of using these term vectors one one
problem that arises pretty quick is you
know the natural idea might be oh I want
to then average these terms the problem
is you you know if I have these various
products kind of represented in spec I
look as I look like the flailing arm guy
so if you have if you have these
products like representative in space
and then you average them together you
kind of drowned out a lot of information
so this is where dr. Beck may be kind of
more appropriate for some of these terms
is it kind of it's looking at the
document itself and trying to produce a
vector representation of that document
not the individual terms and so it
allows you kind of move up a layer of
abstraction which which might be more
useful it also has a kind of similar
similarity functions which which you can
use
so then capes be so that was kind of
like a recommendation system and that
was like oh you know
have these NOP focused algorithms how do
we kind of slant them into to maybe
other applications then then another one
another kind of interesting idea or
maybe kind of more it's closer to two
NLP is actually doing text analytics so
so like I mentioned earlier I looked at
the inaugural addresses over time
don't try to like derive any meaning
from this this is just kind of showing
what you could do so I have the
basically the years running across the
the y-axis from 1789 to 2009 and then I
chose 25 topics so you really wanted to
dive into this you can kind of look at
the the topic trends trends over time
and you might want to look and say you
know maybe kind of in the early days we
were more focused about more focus on
being a union or and then we as we kind
of transitioned into the mid 1800s late
18-hundreds maybe it's more kind of
Industrial Revolution focus things like
that and then as we kind of move and
move later on you get some more topics
and then some kind of changes so you got
to do some interesting trends over time
there's there's a paper around modeling
scientific topics over time which which
i think is a really good paper and it
kind of talks about the power or at
least shows and a really good a really
good manner the power of NLP for kind of
trend analysis and things like that and
why why Lda is a really good choice
there due to its interpretability
interpretability so let's talk about
this kind of analysis real quick I think
but we only have a couple minutes left
so so this is the kind of the corpus you
saw earlier except it's it's changed in
a little bit so there's so there's this
yield key so so kind of what I found is
when working with Jensen is you want to
have kind of one way to produce the
training examples and one way to
actually produce the scoring examples so
the reason I had this yield keys here is
I'm yielding if I want what I can do
here is just yield the the bag of words
to actually do the training but when I'm
doing the scoring later I want to be
able to associate some document or some
document ID with with the score or with
the outcome so that's what that's doing
as I'm just saying okay you know I want
to do this first
I don't want those keys and I just want
to do the training
and when I'm doing the actual analysis I
want to be able to do to associate an ID
there that's that's what I just said
there that's what you said there so then
we have so this is kind of dated like I
guess I would call it generation in
process or kind of like the scoring of
the underlying models so I'm just
creating you know kind of address which
is the inaugural addresses Lda with like
that corpus passed in the number of
topics 25 how many passes I want to do
there's basically no you can you want to
train more so you can get get
convergence depending on how big your
interlined is that is and this idea word
is kind of allows Jensen to translate
between the between tokens and words so
then you can actually do like the data
analysis on it where you there you might
visually iterate through all of the
documents and create this data frame
where you have the president they're
kind of fundamental like topic 2
probability vectors and the year in
question and then and then you would you
know potentially do some plotting or
something like that to kind of produce
produce something that looks like this
so so real quick the kind of takeaways
so hopefully you got enough you know of
an introduction to NLP to be
quote-unquote dangerous so NOP
transformations have different strengths
you know there's the query inside which
I talked about with kind of a word to
Veck example there's the LDA which is a
little bit more probabilistic focus
which which might be nice for kind of
analysis and interpreting results and in
terms of Jen's immuno we kind of talked
about there's this pre-processing stuff
where you have your document you need to
turn it into words or turn it into
something that's useful for later and
then there's the kind of the model
transformation step where after you have
that vector representation of your
underlying documents then you score them
and then you use them further and then
yeah there's this kind of query analysis
to sides - to - NOP kind of focused
focus on what you want so I think I
don't I'm not real good on my time so I
have cool open have having answer
questions or if you want to come up
that that works too okay cool Thanks